hey 42 here as you will see you many a
comment section being first is very
important to some people we're a
competitive race as humans and there's a
never-ending battle to be number one on
the list whether it's for lightning fast
speeds vast sums of money or eating a
frankly worrying volume of food in a
very short time and once your name is in
the history book it's there for good but
that's no guarantee that the general
population will have any idea who the
hell you are sure we know the first man
on the moon the first people to fly but
over firsts become lost to the darkest
corners of Wikipedia so today we're
looking at some little-known but
astonishingly interesting firsts from
history let's start on a nice depressing
war when all the dust has settled the
historians wondering stretching their
lever elbow patches and try to work out
what's on earth happened
so in a war involving so many millions
of deaths does any one individual
casualty have more importance than the
others well maybe Franciszek honey odd
could be described as the first casualty
of world war ii but is much more
important than not Germany and Poland
had an ongoing dispute over their border
and the Nazis being renowned for their
patience decided to take matters into
their own hands honey oak was an
unmarried German farmer with Polish
sympathies on the 30th of August 1939 in
the village of Paolo Mia he was arrested
by the SS the next day the SS squad
dressed as polish to Peters and stormed
a radio station in the city of Gloria
and fired shots into the air one German
officer grabbed the microphone and
shouted in Polish attention this is
Glavine sure the broadcasting station is
now in Polish hands they then left honey
ups body who they had already killed by
injection and filled him with bullet
holes they also added the bodies of over
dead Germans dressed as Polish soldiers
these bodies were then present
as evidence that the Polish were
attacking and the message that was
screamed into the microphone was
broadcast across the country
honey Oaks death was used to justify the
start of the war Nazi propaganda at its
very best
the following morning on 1st of
September 1939 Hitler declared war on
pause I mean it's probably been said
before but the Nazis really were a bunch
of bastards although there are still
inequalities in the world today at least
has been some improvement in the
spectrum of women in powerful positions
and we now have women leading Britain
and Germany and potentially America but
historically we have not really let
women up to the top table but early
because we were embarrassed that we had
got it so messy and now we'd have to
bother to put on pants on there have
been famous queens such as Cleopatra
Catherine the Great and Victoria but
when it came to proper non-royal leaders
it took quite some time for one to
appear Kotak akima taça was the first
female leader of the modern world in
1940 she was made chair of the president
of little Kuro meaning she was the head
of the Tuvan People's Republic toover is
now a part of Russia but it was a member
of the Soviet Union when a key Mitaka
was born - there was just beginning to
form having previously been a part of
the Chinese Empire the Bolsheviks helped
set up the Toobin People's Republic
after the Russian Revolution of 1917 the
new state helped women to read and write
since most were illiterate and a key
Mitaka was one of the first to learn the
new Tuvan alphabet she then worked to
help others gain an education and
eventually won a place in a Moscow
University where she adopted Stalinist
ideology which was pretty important
since if you weren't a member of the
Stalin fan club things like your dinner
family and life often got misplaced
somehow of course it's not just politics
where women have been under represented
it's in the arts as well in 2009
Kathryn Bigelow became the first woman
to win Best Director in 80 years
of the Oscar Awards Hurt Locker was the
gritty story of a bomb disposal team in
Iraq but despite it brilliant
it only took home 12 million dollars at
the box office
ironically it beats avatar in the Oscar
race directed by Bigelow's ex-husband
James Cameron which is the
highest-grossing film of all time
Bigelow had a previous box-office smash
with Point Break where she tried
numerous times to kill off Keanu Reeves
by throwing him out of planes and
sending him up into a giant wave but
unfortunately she was unsuccessful and
had to allow him to continue to act the
film is such a cult classic that there
is now a touring stage show called clink
great live since they don't have a spare
broomstick to act Keanu's part they fill
it in every night with a different
member of the audience Julia Phillips
was actually the first woman to win an
Oscar for best film when she was a
producer on the classic conman tale the
sting of a notable Oscar firsts are
Hattie McDaniel the first black Oscar
winner a supporting actress in Gone with
the Wind and of course Leonardo DiCaprio
who probably deserves a mention as the
most historically unsuccessful nominee
to finally win an Oscar good on you leo
it's a good job he did before he
eventually snapped and went on man vs.
bear on the audience now we can't talk
about firsts without talking about
sports and where better to look than the
Olympics the modern Olympics was first
held in athletes and American James
Connolly won the very first gold medal
for the triple jump the 100-meter has
often been the headline act and Jim
Hines holds the official records the
first man to run it in under 10 seconds
with 9.95 seconds in the 1968 final that
had been over suck ten times before with
American Bob Hayes being the first you
ever make it on paper what a rule change
about timing and wind speeds in 1977
meant that these times were no longer
recognized physicists think it's
unlikely that the world record will ever
go below nine point four seconds and
surprisingly the best hope
surely the Paralympics since the blades
made famous by Oscar Pistorius are
lighter than a human leg and can
increase the time connected with the
ground and so apply more force and
finally let's talk about love on the 1st
of April 2001
Helene fussing and Ann Marie thus became
the first gay couple to get married in
the modern era along with three other
pairs of gay men the wedding took place
in Amsterdam and since then we have seen
about 20 countries follow suit by making
it legal the fingers gay marriage is not
a new thing at all no one batted an
eyelid when Roman Emperor Nero completed
a love triangle by marrying a Friedman
called Pythagoras and later a young boy
called Sporus perceivably chose him for
his very small size so the sum of him
and Nero
squared was equal to pythagoras squirt
there's also Pedro Deus and Muno
Vandellas two men married in a Galatian
Church in 1061 and let's not forget the
sea were oasis in Egypt which used to
have it's very own form of same-sex
marriage in its law so with so many
firsts already ticked off the list
you're gonna have to get creative if you
want to join the annals of the great
maybe try inventing your own sports or
developing your own language or if you
want to be a real maverick start
preparing to be the very first person to
buy the revolutionary iPhone 8 which
will feature no headphone jack and no
screen you'll be paying more for less
sure people will think you're crazy but
at least you'll be first thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2 some
photos can tell rich detailed stories
others inspire a thousand questions the
two and a half thousand happy residents
of my Aki Islands have nothing but good
words to say about their cozy little
home look they are practically welcoming
you with open arms